[Music]
are you very popular in Korea you have
any ideas are you like a national hero
there yeah well you know I was I was
actually in Korea what is wrong with
saying a national hero you know
everything right
the I was I was in Korea promoting
hangover too like two years ago and the
studio executive from Warner Brothers
Korea was like uh excuse me uh don't to
get too mad that but uh you know one
know you here you're not popular no one
know you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
and I'm like truthfully this really did
happen and I said you know it's fine
I'll it'll be nice to be anonymous and I
really enjoy that oh no you didn't you
do not and uh you can fit about uh no
one like you all right okay I get it my
15 minutes are up I get it and then and
then no no no you still do not
understand and so I actually you know
subsequently that day I went walking in
a mall in Seoul and I got mobbed it
literally it was just you know you know
it's like social like Twitter and social
media has totally globalized
entertainment and then people like oh oh
oh that's a Ken Jeong the self-aware
annoying guy yeah
he knows he annoys the guy in the
Corvette's there
[Music]
all right we have a clip here from The
Hangover Part 3 and I believe this is
where they can't find you the guys the
work pack can't find you they're waiting
for you sort of on a stakeout to see if
they can get you exactly and I think
Zach Galifianakis is the bait yes this
is chow and Alan play by Zach Meetup
let's take a look you know you were
right
about what that place in Arizona it's
not gonna help them
there is no facility that can fix this
guy we're gonna spend the rest of our
lives dealing with him because we're all
he has now everyone is that we're it
is that ciao hey fat stuff lastly I
thought that Matt cool eyes oh yeah okay
quick give me some sugar
come on back
did he just kiss him